on a avec nous donne l jackson
humoristes vous avez été victime de
propos racistes pendant l'un de vos
sketches merci donald's d'être là je
suis très très fan de toi tu le sais on
sait qu'on se connaît depuis des années
tu es un garçon voilà que j'aime
énormément kaki atout qui fait que des
conneries et voilà et qu'ils étaient
tranquillement spectacle c'était le 23
décembre dernier à nice tu étais en
plein spectacle et a été victime
d'insultés racistes on a tous vu ces
images qu'on va vous remonterez regarder
les gens qui votent front national parce
que c'est ce qui m'énerve c'est que les
assume pas souvent but le seul à suivre
c'est cool ça j'aurai la maladie à part
de la gêne pour toi pour déjeuner
et tu te dis sur l'aide du moteur alors
donald's je vois au départ mais c'est
vrai que même nous on quand on a vu la
vidéo ou zim malentendu liens et eric
menneteau débuté suite il dit au début
je croyais pas j'étais surpris c c'est
alors que c'est comme parle au delà dans
ton émission je suis surpris à une
ambiance je connais pas gérer ses
besoins là dans notre émission pas à ça
c'est ça qu'on aime ça il ya une
ambiance au 2e
l' union d'alcooliques anonymes autres
jeux dévoileront pendant l'émission
takahashi content vraiment humain vite
et on se connaît mais je le dire quand
même séquence comme quand ça m'arrive et
cyril sont que le contact sans rien on a
parlé ici samaras m'a vraiment touché
non sans arrêt un message valérie qui
hélas de réparer d'autres montants
d'émissions avec beaucoup de
bienveillance donc déjà merci beaucoup
c'est normal et ça à bras le corps ce
match les du bien et quand ça s'est
passé ça s'ils croient pas au début
c'est sympa normal sud en masse à
hordain ferme en spectacle je suis pas
super connu au point que j'attire stand
n étais je suis pas djamel je passais
mec là donc en plus les mecs qui sait il
y voit sur la fiche yvon un noir
arrivent et insultes à noir donc ça
n'avait aucun aucun sens mais je me suis
dit peut-être que le mec c'était une
vanne raté était construit du stand-up
des fois mais qui tombe des vannes c'est
vrai que demande une deuxième fois pour
laisser une chance de s'excuser ou de
s'enterrer dans son siège et il continue
je me dis c'est peut-être de la provoc
je fais une troisième fois et là ils
disent ces sondes arrêtons qui m'énerve
c'est quand il fait j'ai dit fall noir
cyan sous texte va faire quoi
et là je me dis je vais le laisser
tranquille et à la fin du spectacle je
l'attrapé pour pour faire autre chose
mais à la fin de ce tas qui était parti
non mais et donc ils sont issus du coeur
avec sont les autres spectateurs c'est
ça ils ont rigolé parce que tu étais pas
prêt à ça tu te dis c'est le spectacle
c'est un complice il est resté jusqu'à
la fin du spectacle était dans le noir
donc je sais pas en fait je me suis dit
je vais pas le mettre en lumière je suis
il a tenté un coup mais je vais y
répondre et plus le calcul et tu vois
que mes comme si dans le noir j'ai pas
vu tu as été perturbé après sur la fin
du spectacle
ouais parce que tu tues tu te dis est ce
que j'aurais dû faire autrui autrement
en pointant je jouais en fait en train
de me dire qu'est ce que j'aurais dû
peut-être arrêter j'aurais dû sauter
dans l'aude
sur lui aujourd'hui faire un tour plus
violent ces 11 jours je vous posais
pense que tu as eu la bonne réaction
mais vraiment je pense va